jim gamble he's the senior child
protection officer in the uk's first
investigation into the disappearance of
madeleine mccann good afternoon to you
mr gamble how significant is this
well i think it's really important and
not least because the clock has been
ticking on the statute of limitations
that exists within the portuguese legal
framework
and but moreover than that i think if
the portuguese authorities now a fee
label
to identify this individual as a person
of interest in their investigation and
designate them are guido
and then they must believe they have
significant amounts of evidence yeah
that's what i was going to ask you i
mean is this about the clock running
down on being able to charge somebody or
do you think that there is
genuinely new information
well i don't think anyone's surprised
that the clock's been ticking there was
conversations about three or four months
ago that indeed um you know you were
moving towards that period where the
statute of limitations in portugal may
kick in and what that would do would
limit the portuguese ability to hold an
individual to account not for example
the germans
but i think it's more than that because
there is a legitimate argument that says
well even if they've gone beyond the
third of may which is next week beyond
the 15 years they could perhaps have
made an application to a court to say
look with the pandemic with with
backlogs and we could make an exception
but they they aren't having to do that
now so that's a good thing but i do
believe that
certainly i am tilting more to the fact
that they have their own information the
information that the german authorities
have collected and indeed
operation grange and new scotland jarred
will undoubtably have shared so i hope
noy is the time when the portuguese
feels sufficiently confident
on the back of this to apply for the
extradition of the subject so that he
can be interviewed in portugal by them
now this individual denies any
involvement with madeleine mccann it's
important to say but what do we know
about him and
why the interest in him
well i think it's right to highlight the
fact that he denies any involvement and
he's not even charged with this
particular offense at this time but what
we do know about him is that he's you
know an unscrupulous
character you know he's someone that
that you wouldn't want to be looking
after your children or engaging with you
in any place he's a convicted rapist
the key issues around this for me
are that he's someone that's been known
to the investigation since at the
earliest of times he was known
and
for example
uh
in 2011 he was in information that was
passed to the british police as they
took over
and the
their part of the investigation in 2012
and the germans had a tip off about him
in 2013 so he's not new to the table
and i think there are some
factors around the circumstantial
evidence that tilts towards him that are
really really interesting and quite
significant in themselves
like what
well for example um proximity and
thereby opportunity and and his profile
so
you we can put him
um or at least the phone attributed to
him in proximity of the the mccann's
apartment on the evening that the crime
took place
that's significant what we also know is
here's a man who lived in that part of
predalus from 1995 to 2007 a man who
would later be convicted from the rape
of an older woman in 2005 in that same
area a man that court papers disclose um
has been involved in the burglaries of
hotel rooms
and holiday lets
a man that that we know
um has had indecent images of children
on a thumb drive an individual when
their camper van was searched you know
who was in possession or constructive
possession of children's clothing so
when you start to take one of those
things in isolation you could maybe
unpick it but when you put them all
together
i would say that
whilst we are not a court of law we
cannot find him guilty but what you can
see are the clear lines of inquiry the
levels of corroboration that you would
expect and for him to be made the person
of interest and that the portuguese have
made him so so i think
they would be wanting
you know in their duty if they didn't
know and bring him back to portugal and
put the questions that they have to him
over the 15 years jim you'll know more
than most that there have been many
false storms haven't there um in the
search for madeleine mccann
just in terms of your gut feeling does
it feel like
this could
unlock
the answer
you know
my gut feeling in 2020 when the german
police began to unpack the information
they had about this individual was that
this felt
more right than anything else that we've
had up until that moment in time and the
other thing about the the german police
investigation is if you listen to the
german prosecutor speaking and the
police officers you know there's a level
of confidence in what they're saying
that i think
is important because having worked with
german police before they they don't say
things
and they don't make false promises they
don't build you know hope and
anticipation for no reason that's not
that that's not the culture that exists
there so i think there's something
significant
there's something significant sorry
there's something significant in that
and i do believe that
that this case at this moment in time
represents the best opportunity that
that i've seen in 15 years of
of being in the in the margins of this
case